congratulations on the album thank you
very much feel really really big for you
at this time it does it's it it's it's
so much less overwhelming than the than
the first album though I think maybe
because I've got some time under my belt
yeah um and I feel like because I got so
much off my chest on this it's oh it
feels much more freeing um I just I told
myself that I really wanted to enjoy it
this time I don't know if I really I
feel like I worked and worked and worked
and worked more to work so much last
time late I don't know if I really have
to enjoy it so this time I'm I'm
enjoying every moment of it that's
awesome
so yeah I read somewhere where you said
that this album really saved your life
can you talk a little bit about that
yeah I was really I don't know I feel
like a different person and in a
different phase of my life and I was
just scrambling and to have to have
something that's so I don't know healing
such as music for for me I think it's
really important for anyone whether
they're depressed or not depressed to
have some form of creative outlet it's
so important that for your just your
spirit you know and so for me to have
this come into my life at a time when I
didn't know that I need it so much and
for me it's like okay we've got to go
back to work but really music has is and
always has been a very healing thing for
me so I got to really express myself and
I got to really work through a lot of
demons and get a lot of things off my
chest and I don't know it was a very
healing thing do you remember where you
were when you decided no I'm I'm gonna
be really open and honest because I mean
there's a decision there you didn't have
to you didn't have to do it that way but
you at one point you'd open all feet all
in and said I'm gonna tell these stories
I don't honestly I don't know if it was
like a conscious decision I just I made
songs as I went throughout I mean the
last year and a half or the year and a
half that it took to make the record I
literally just made music all along the
way
and I mean with the band we made at
least 25 songs and me alone I made an an
extra 20 on top of that and so I just I
think it's it wasn't too hard to pick
the best songs but it wasn't I don't
know it would didn't even really have to
I guess it told a story but and what was
the best representation and and and what
songs I really felt emotionally tied to
the most and I don't know I wish that I
could say that I had that much thought
put into it it really just kind of as
well told a story yeah right
you know I remember you you've been so
open about PTSD and depression and it's
so brave of you and you're also helping
so many people because people suffer
silently do you feel that love coming
back oh my gosh I honestly I wouldn't I
wouldn't be as as open as I am now if I
didn't feel a total outpour of
acceptance and love and empathy and
kindness and so I just feel like when I
started talking about it last year and I
I was really open on social media I
didn't know I think I was totally just
crying out for help but if I didn't
receive such warmth I don't think I'd
talk about it but they're the reason I
am talking about it is because I'm like
if you reach out and you and you talk
about these hard things you're more than
likely gonna get love and kindness back
and acceptance and and that's a really
like that's a really important thing to
say I think mm-hmm and was there anyone
in your life you know where you talked
about I was just watching some things we
were talking about you had to shake
shake your body off in and just bring
the good back in bring in the vibes
bring in the the genuine feeling of love
and acceptance was there a person who
helped you get to that space or did you
do that on your own because that can be
a lot of work um I mean I guess maybe I
don't really take enough credit I
because I even though I felt so so so
lonely I really was surrounded by my
band you know the Brethren I can't sing
their praises enough
but a lot of it really was a very
internal I guess battle that you know I
had to kind of confront things and face
things head-on and I had you can't you
can't force someone to change and if I
mean even if you really try it won't
have any lasting effects and so I really
wanted I had reached points in my life
where I didn't want to feel that way
anymore and and so I yeah I chain I
changed my own life and I reached out
but at the same time I really was
blessed with amazing support from my
band and it's you know five guys that
are just you know with there's a whole
thing in the world about you know the
men and women battling in blah blah blah
but all I can speak for is the guys that
are surrounding me and I mean there are
good men in the world and I happen to
know six of them and I love them so much
and they were there for me and and you
know there's there's there's more people
that believed in me and really helped me
along the way and everyone waited for
you to come to your own and then support
you and keep bringing you back up yeah
they met me where I was at and they knew
that I needed them and they didn't
abandon me which i think is a huge thing
I mean I've experienced a lot of people
just like well nope nope I can't do it
unless you're below it's like well you
know you don't really have to jump ship
you know it's like I'm gonna get there
get there yeah you know just you know
don't leave me hanging and dry and and
my friends they didn't and so I just
feel really grateful and and it's just
another driving force of like pushing
and talking about this and sharing it
and we made something that we believe in
so much and this I mean music is so
universal and I don't know if people
have been through what I've been through
or what my band has been through but I
do know that people can understand
feeling lonely and feeling sad or having
your heart broken yes yeah so it's just
I don't know it's an interesting thing
to talk about and and you're bringing
people together by doing so which is a
really beautiful thing are there songs
that you're excited
to sing on stage and songs maybe that
you're a little apprehensive to sing on
stage totally yeah
I mean it's been a little nerve-wracking
because I'm not to toot my own horn but
I had a really big song and people all
over the world they they knew like the
words and everything and then you I this
is my first time putting out new music
really since that and so it's like does
anybody know that it was anybody could
stay long do they even live on with me
no it's it's been really interesting and
really exciting and this tour has been
so beautiful in every night Pete you
know it's I'm getting gating more time
since album came out and people are
singing along and and I can tell that
it's you know it's affecting people in
there and they've got that connection
because that was that was a huge huge
driving force for the first album yeah
like we're connecting and we feel the
same
you understand me and I understand you
and and that was such a beautiful thing
and so I'm looking forward to you know
the life of this album about Megan yeah
so it's just like beautiful surprises
and I just can't wait to see what this
will do amazing you've reached a certain
amount of Fame with everything that's
been happening right with the albums and
everything is it is it what you thought
it would be is it better is it worse I
don't know I always say expect nothing
and hope for the best
um there were I feel like I it's kind of
unfair because I grew up with a dad
that's famous and so I kind of it's not
like I just came you know from from
nowhere I had a I had a weird
perspective of it as a young kid and so
I think it may twist my my real
perception of it now so I don't know
like I don't consider myself famous I I
really I have not amazing by the way
that's amazing and good for you but I
mean I do get recognized a lot of places
that I go to and it still is just like
oh but person who ever was that's so
cool they know my music but it's just a
weird thing but I think maybe because of
my dad and all the people that I grew up
with I don't really see it
I guess and and I think I'm thankful for
that because I genuinely do feel like
I'm a normal person I just have a job
that a lot of people know about you know
that's amazing person with like this
incredible voice and can put out this
amazing music and this but you keep
saying you can think about you keep
doing it working my goodness now I have
to ask this I'm a bit of a spiritual
person and I heard that you read tarot
cards
I do you carry them I don't I'm here no
I don't have them on me I wouldn't read
yours I would totally be into that I do
I do like it I think you know all of
that stuff Tarot or even astrology I
think like I'll read my horoscope and
sometimes in like if it's something good
I'm like yep that's me that's why if
it's not like that doesn't mean me
that's it it's just all about what you
want to take in and what you accept and
allow and I just think it's interesting
and I'm always interested in new ways to
kind of broaden my horizon a little and
and find out new kind of avenues to get
information but it is what you make it
and I tried to steer clear of any evil
stuff negative energy I mean I always
like have crystals in my pockets
I always carry crystals in my pocket I
love it yeah they're so good for you yes
it's just interesting I mean I moved to
California and I'm just like a hippie
now yeah that's cool that's it well the
next time you're in we'll do the car
yeah we'll do the whole thing will read
astrology zone and it'll be amazing yes
yes oh my gosh I read by November 4 KO
my gosh I haven't read November yet it's
a good ok ok great great over so it's
gonna be great
amazing ok thank you so much for coming
at you